[Music]
welcome back
so we're talking a lot about how to
model dynamical systems using modern
tools in machine learning
and so i want to tell you about a really
cool kind of
perspective on how to model systems with
with machine learning
uh called discrepancy modeling so often
times when
you know when we're trying to use some
new machine learning technique to
show that we can learn dynamical systems
you know learn how a system evolves in
time learn a turbulent fluid
system or something like that we do an
end-to-end learning we act like we don't
know anything about our system
and we try to learn everything from
scratch
and that's kind of cool to demonstrate
capabilities to demonstrate that you can
learn these complex systems
but instead of trying to discover a
model from scratch with no
prior knowledge it's much more realistic
that you would start with some partial
knowledge of the physics
maybe you have an idealized model like a
hamiltonian or a lagrangian for
you know a double pendulum or for an
automobile an autonomous vehicle
maybe you know something about
constraints that have to be satisfied or
symmetries conservation laws for your
system
and you don't know the exact dynamics
but you have this kind of partial
physical knowledge
that you are starting with and so
instead of
discovering the model from scratch with
machine learning
i think it's much more reasonable
oftentimes
to try to learn so you start with this
imperfect model
and you might want to focus your machine
learning efforts
in modeling the discrepancy the part of
your model that doesn't fit your data
okay that's i think a more realistic way
of how we might approach
autonomous systems and robots
learning fast and on the fly is starting
with an imperfect or idealized model
and then focusing the machine learning
uh effort on the discrepancy
so today i'm going to talk a little bit
about how you might do that
and also talk about kind of a little bit
more almost of the philosophy
of when you would want to learn end to
end
when you would want your machine
learning models to capture that
discrepancy
and when you wouldn't and this will have
some kind of historical
connotations with things like you know
the universal law of gravity and things
like that
so here's an example i really like by
kadir dan kamen
who is a phd student working with nathan
cuts in me
and this is a double pendulum apparatus
in my lab
in mechanical engineering at university
of washington
and you can see so this uh this setup
here what he's trying to do is swing it
up
and stabilize this inverted double
pendulum which is a relatively simple
mechanical system you know on a piece of
paper you can derive
the lagrangian or the hamiltonian and
you can derive the equations of motion
you know from those those frameworks but
it turns out that when you use that
idealized hamiltonian or lagrangian
model
for control design there are
imperfections in that model that make it
very hard to
accurately and efficiently swing up and
stabilize the system
so what are those imperfections look
like things like
non-linear bearing chatter in the joints
or
wind resistance those are things that we
typically don't model
in our first principles physics or at
least it's difficult to do so
but when you include a discrepancy model
using kind of machine learning
techniques when you when you model the
discrepancy of your idealized model
with the experimental data you can start
capturing those subtle effects
in in this discrepancy model and then
you can do pretty remarkable
control uh tasks like swing up and
stabilize this double pendulum
i just love this video i'm gonna keep
showing it because it's it's awesome
uh he this is the old rig this is the
the original rig that ben strom started
building
and now cardi has a new
triple pendulum set up uh fancy new rig
it's more expensive than my car and
hopefully i'll show you a video of that
sometime soon but it's super cool okay
so that's the idea of discrepancy
modeling though you want to augment your
idealized model
with all of the terms and really subtle
physics like wind resistance and bearing
chatter
that are hard to model from first
principles
and so we can kind of look at this on
two axes going from easy to hard
so on the x-axis what you have is
modeling disturbances and unknown
physics
so this is where you know your your
bearing chatter and your wind resistance
comes in
and it's very difficult to model those
with first principles physics you know
pencil and paper textbook physics it's
hard to model
bearing chatter and wind resistance for
example
and on the other axis you have uh
how difficult is it to incorporate known
physics so for example in that double
pendulum i know
that there are you know these
constraints that my system is
constrained
uh to be you know in angular coordinates
theta one and theta two
i could write it in x one x two or sorry
x
x y coordinates and cartesian
coordinates but i would need to know
that that system enforces some
constraints these these bearing
constraints
and that's actually oftentimes very hard
for machine learning
to learn it's hard to learn that the
hamiltonian energy is conserved or that
my system is constrained to live on a
circle or
some toroidal configuration space
and so i think this is a really
interesting uh kind of set of axes to
show
why you want these hybrid discrepancy
models there are some things that are
easy
for machine learning to do like they can
learn those bearing chatter and wind
resistance models just by
collecting data the first principles
models can learn that the hamiltonian
energy should be conserved and that the
system is constrained to live on a
taurus and so you want to get the best
of both worlds you don't want to do
everything with first principles or
everything with machine learning you
want to find some sweet spot in the
middle between these where you're
getting the best of both worlds
and hopefully this curve actually is
more like a pareto optimal curve
where there's kind of an optimal elbow
here where our discrepancy models live
we get as much as we can with the first
principles and we bake in as much prior
knowledge as we can
and then everything that our first
principles model can't capture like that
wind resistance
we're going to model that discrepancy
with machine learning
and that machine learning can be
anything it could be a deep neural
network it could be a dynamic mode
decomposition model
a sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics a gaussian
process model you know this is not just
a deep neural network
but it's something that is kind of data
intensive or data informed model okay
that that's what i think of as
machine learning so this is a sweet spot
where you get the best of both worlds
and you can apply this to lots of
systems so i showed you that
swing up of the double pendulum this is
a
robotic arm in our boeing advanced
research center or
bark this system you know again it has
as this system ages
the way that the joints move and the way
that the motors behave
changes in time and so these discrepancy
models can also be very important when
you're building digital twins
and you want to incorporate things like
aging or you know different environments
things like that
good so just to kind of very very
briefly summarize
this idea is that you're going to kind
of use first principles physics
where it's good you know here in our
imperfect model
to enforce things like constraints and
conservation laws and symmetries
and we're going to use machine learning
for what it's good at which is you know
modeling the really hairy hard to
quantify bits
from data and you're going to put those
together and hopefully get something
that's easy to train
and satisfies kind of your rudimentary
physics
okay now i at this point you know
that's the the kind of guts of the idea
but i want to pull back and talk a
little bit about how this has
historically uh manifest itself and some
of the key takeaways and caveats we
as engineers can can learn about how and
when we should apply machine learning to
model dynamical systems
and what might go wrong so i show this
movie sometimes i really like this
visualization by maulin christerson
which shows kind of the difference
between these two
world views of the earth-centric solar
system and the sun-centric solar system
and you can see of course that um
if you put the earth at the center of
the solar system which is what people
thought for
you know a thousand plus years the
dynamics are very very complicated okay
it's hard to get a simple
idealized model that describes uh this
behavior here
and it's much simpler to get a simple
model when you have the right coordinate
system
but what i want to point out here is
that
you know it took a long time for us to
go from the aristotelian model
uh of i'm sorry the the patol may
ptolemies
model of circles on circles in the
earth-centric system to kepler's
laws of motion here in the sun-centric
system in this copernican system
and what i'll point out is the ptolemy's
system
which is in the wrong coordinate system
it's the wrong physics
it was actually more accurate uh for a
long time than kepler's model
that had the right physics that had the
sun at the center of the solar system
and so to some extent there were these
discrepancies uh
unmeasured variables planets we didn't
know about yet
uh and forces that we couldn't predict
that made it so that kepler's actual
correct
uh idealized physics model was not as
good of a fit as tolmi's model
and i think that this is a really
important point for us as machine
learning engineers when we learn
dynamical systems
it's easy to over fit uh to the data
that the tolmak model is essentially a
fourier transform of the solar system
data
and it was extremely accurate more
accurate
uh than than the right model because
there were discrepancies because there
were planets that hadn't been measured
and so you have to think about you know
kind of what core
bits you're trying to to measure and
model
okay another example i really like to
think about is
uh galileo's ball drop experiment so
you know in some sense galileo and this
famous ball drop experiment
you know where he dropped two balls of
different densities and they fell at the
same
rate and they hit the ground at the same
time this is a very well crafted
uh experiment and i think that there's a
lot of kind of historical uh
kind of retellings or or small
fictions that go on with this story so
if you look at galileo's ball drop
experiment this is essentially supposed
to prove that there is a universal
kind of law of gravitation a
gravitational constant
and that objects fall at the same rate
regardless of their densities
but we know that that's not entirely
true all of us you know if you dropped a
beach ball
and a bowling ball they do fall at
different rates because there are these
additional forces
it's not just gravity acting on on those
objects you also have fluid forces you
have
drag forces viscous drag forces and
you know turbulent forces on those
different objects
and so you know for example if you
increase the velocity
of a falling object you go through all
of these different drag regimes as the
fluid forces
change and bifurcate according to very
very complicated physics
and so to some extent uh you know
galileo's ball drop experiment trying to
say
that these balls fall at exactly the
same rate because there is one
you know constant acceleration of
gravity
that is neglecting a bunch of
discrepancy physics
there are discrepancies in those ball
drops uh that is not captured by the
model and you have to ignore those
if you want to uncover that kind of you
know constant acceleration of gravity
and in fact galileo did not just
discover this by
dropping balls off of you know the
leaning tower of pisa
he did very careful experiments so sorry
let me take a step back
if you actually collected data and you
were
you know not dropping dense balls but
you were dropping beach balls and
basketballs and wiffle balls and golf
balls
you would very likely not come up with
galileo's
constant acceleration it's much more
likely you would come up with
aristotle's model
that uh the rate at which a ball falls
or or moves through the air is somehow
proportional to
its mass or its density that actually
seems
very consistent if i throw a baseball
it's going to go way farther
than if i throw a beach ball because the
drag of that beach ball is somehow
related to its density
okay and so you know this was the
leading model for again
over a thousand years because it fit the
data better
and so to some extent you have to kind
of divorce the discrepancies
and the different types of physical
forces that are at play in a system
if you want to uncover kind of the
universal idealized model which is what
galileo did
and you know in some sense what galileo
did was not just drop balls off of
the leaning tower of pisa he also did
other
very careful experiments looking at how
pendulum oscillated in very controlled
still
environments and looking at how balls
would roll down ramps of different
inclines
so he could control the kind of drag
forces
and those discrepancies and control for
those additional effects
okay and i think this is an extremely
important uh
cautionary tale again for us as machine
learning engineers when we
have a new system like you know we're
trying to learn how
balls move you know or fall through the
air and we want to learn the physics
chances are much more likely that we're
going to learn aristotle's model
which is not kind of the true underlying
physics
because it is a better fit to the data
because of those discrepancy terms
because of the the complexity of the
real world and fluid drag forces
and so that's a really important
philosophical question you have to ask
yourself
which one do i want to learn it's it's a
fair question do i want to learn
you know that there is a constant
acceleration of gravity
and all balls should fall at the same
rate in a you know perfect world
or do i want to learn the full hairy
turbulent drag
physics and get a more accurate model of
how real balls would fall
that's a fair question and in different
circumstances you would want to learn
different models so you have to keep
that in mind
and so there's a set of experiments that
were conducted
this is work with brian da silva when he
was a phd student with nathan cuts and
myself
and uh some of nathan's collaborators
essentially did this experiment they
took all of these different balls
and they dropped them from uh i think it
was you know the the roof of a
five-story parking garage and they they
watched and tracked their motion as they
fell to the ground
so you have golf balls uh tennis balls
baseballs wiffle balls basketballs
okay all different densities all
different uh kind of drag profiles
and so if you look at the data this is
kind of you know the height
and this is strobostop stroboscopic
measurements as they fell from you know
whatever 40 meters
down you see that they all fall at
different rates
again the the actual raw data is more
like
the aristotelian model that it somehow
depends on their density
and if you plot kind of the height over
time you see that they all take
different trajectories
and these dashed lines are kind of
different models of the physics so this
is the idealized gravity with no
no friction and then the kind of white
and yellow dash lines are having some
velocity-based drag model and again this
is just
that same data on a log plot so you see
that the data doesn't actually support
just one of these models right like it's
all over the place
and so you know we can do a number of
experiments this was
using our sparse identification of
nonlinear dynamics algorithm
where you put in a candidate set of
terms that could describe the
acceleration
and just with regression you try to see
which terms best
describe the data and for these
different balls
over you know multiple drops you get
different terms showing up
and disappearing you know you get
spurious term this x should not be there
this v squared shouldn't be there you
know so this is the wrong physics
according to galileo
now if you add a group sparsity
penalty so what you say is that the same
physics has to be true the same terms
have to be there for
all of the balls across all the drops if
you add
group sparsity you then kind of
rule out all of those spurious terms and
you learn the actual dynamics
that x double dot the acceleration is
equal to a constant
of magnitude 9.8 right gravity
and there is a kind of drag
or a dissipation term that's
proportional to its velocity
that's the very very simple
velocity-based drag model
and so again great care has to go into
how you constrain your machine learning
algorithm to learn
the correct physics because the actual
data
you know doesn't support that it says
that there
are density dependent terms there's
other physics that's more likely to
describe your data
if you just look at you know a wiffle
ball falling
and so i just found this to be extremely
uh kind of
enlightening for for myself i know we've
talked about this a lot
um you know our group and it really does
start to beg the question what kind of
model do you want
do you want a model that actually
captures all of this variation between
these different types of balls that does
have a density
term in there and does capture that you
know turbulent drag wake
of these balls or do you want something
more like galileo's
simple idealized physics this is kind of
related to that problem of discrepancy
modeling
and how you how you model and how you
control your learning process
so really important idea uh you know
when you're modeling
systems with machine learning to think
about what kind of what kind of model do
you want do you want an idealized model
that you can analyze and learn from that
that kind of generalizes well
or do you want a model that just with
brute force fits your data
more accurately do you want galileo or
do you want aristotle
all right thank you